welcome back to new rock stars what if
episode 9 brought together the guardians
of the multiverse to take down the
universe killer ultron and even though
uatu sort of told them the whole plan he
still kind of just sat back and let them
do all the dirty work and we finally got
a zola face on the robot's chest finally
i've wanted this forever and we finally
got zola tube on the chest like in the
comics so good but he's locked away in a
pocket dimension free zola this is rogue
theory the show where we pitch the
wildest theories for the nerdy titles we
love my name is mt and going rogue with
me today with the battle cry of viva las
vegas is jessica clemens what's going on
that scene killed me you guys know i
love good comedy you guys know i like
good villain but that line
party though
rock on
rock
steady freaking love party thor honestly
you bring them to the mcu we don't need
regular thor anymore
uh the most likely to do the margarita
anyway and just waiting to unleash the
infinity crusher on any multiversal
threat it's whitney van landingham
what's going on whitney
not a lot just hanging out
yo your hair is fire by the way as a
bald person who wishes he had hair
i i i envy you thank you thank you thank
you you and brandon
greatest locks on the nation and finally
free from the pocket dimension it's
eddie villanueva what's going on eddie
my man what is up i just got out and
ready to have some fun and uh they'll
probably send me back but it's all right
i got a couple minutes to spare
hey that's what uwatu does apparently
it's like hey i just need to borrow you
for a second then i'm going to put you
back into your little pocket i'll put
you right back
so rude but anyways the final episode of
season 1 of what if had huatu declaring
himself the protector of the multiverse
and for our first topic today i have to
ask you all
who or what will be the big threat of
season two will killmonger or zola
escape the pocket dimension and what's
next for captain carter based on her
reunion with skinny steve and will
natasha play nice in her new universe
what do you guys think damn so we just
call him skinny steve now
we're calling him malnourished steve
there you go that's what i call him
malnourished
tiny steve is his nickname
now that skinny steve is back
i i feel like next season we're kind of
in a gray area in terms of we have this
protection from what's going on with the
infinity stones from one of the
universes but i would i would personally
like to see the storyline for the next
season kick off with the storyline from
original sin like i would love to see
where uatu has been officially announced
as you know he's he's obviously going to
get ousted from his order because we've
talked about this before in the show
he's going to get ousted from the rest
of the watchers and at that point i feel
like it's going to be a moment where
what we've already established the
multiverse so the other universe nick
fury's going to come in
and other entities and we're going to
i'm not cause i don't wanna give away a
lot of that storyline it's a great
storyline and it leads to a lot of
different offshoots but uh i'd love to
see the uh storyline of original sin
being kicked off where we have the
assassination of the watcher um and that
that whole storyline is is is delved in
like espionage and secrets and stuff and
everything else in cosmic uh situations
and environments and it's a great
storyline so i'd like to see it go in
that direction where uh we we're gonna
see that
kicked off either in the first episode
or at the end of the first episode okay
cool cool so an original sin like ever
since we got to watch i was like bro i
really hope we do original sin because
there is a really crazy thing that
happens in the middle of original sin
that it's just really messy it's really
messy yeah for the marvel universe
that's all i'm going to say uh so please
go read the original sin um but okay so
but what do you think um is going to
happen with captain carter and skinny
steve like how do you think that's going
to
affect season two i feel like we're
going to get a really kind of pen or not
pandora
uh schrodinger's box when it comes to uh
steve because we don't know in what
state he's in this isn't like the same
thing with bucky where if he's been in
stasis this entire time they just said
and somebody's in there for all we know
there's a body that's like or a skeleton
you know that could be just like a
really technologically advanced coffin
for all we know i i don't really want to
uh get my hopes up yet but i feel like
this is going to lead toward at least uh
captain carter getting closure um
because much like in the array in the
original storyline where steve got a
chance to see peggy before you know she
passed uh she was in a very you know
medical state that just wasn't great and
it just it kicked off that whole part
where steve had to move on with his life
this might be the opportunity where
we're gonna get peggy uh to have that
opportunity to move on with her life and
get that closure she needs
um so that would be so
it kind of would be pretty up if
the widow was just like you wanna know
something that's gonna blow your mind i
have your boyfriend and he's right here
baby okay check it out his skull looks
dead
he's just a hundred percent dead his
skeleton crumbles
yeah should have maybe should have maybe
scanned for vital signs first
[Laughter]
peggy go wait at the door real
quick hold on
[Laughter]
so okay so you're saying that you you
want a original sim scenario and you're
thinking that you know we shouldn't
really assume that skinny steve is in
the hydro stomper yeah
i just i feel like they're not going to
take that any i just i don't know if
they're going to take that anywhere in
terms of the storyline i would love to
like realistically speaking i would love
to but honestly for the course of like
the progression of the story i feel like
it's gonna mirror we've done a great job
marvel has done a great job of mirroring
certain key uh what is that absolute
points or something of that nature uh in
in the storyline and i think this is one
of those ones where one can exist at
their peak with the other support at
their side so one of them's going to
have to prevail and one of them's going
to have to be the
send off bleak i go for bleak not just
bully
that's great where do you go the ladies
what you got first of all we've got uh
dr strange babysitting
a hydro nazi and black panther locked in
an eternal battle inside of a polly
pocket with the most powerful weapons in
the multiverse inside so it's like what
could go wrong uh lots of things
maybe maybe lots of things could go
wrong next season um one of the things
that i was kind of thinking about uh
kind of along the same lines of the uatu
thing is that he's got to have a
consequence for interfering right like
something
there has to be some kind of consequence
because he broke his big big rule so i
think that it is possible that we are
going to see
some consequences of him like rick
sanchezing black widow into that
universe where he's like all right you
guys lost your rick so here's rick c137
for you guys he just like inserted
natasha romanov scene literally what he
did like into
into that universe and he was like well
it's not your it's not your widow but
she'll have to do and
uh my only advice is baby girl don't
clone your daughter don't don't take
your grandpa your grandkid on
intergalactic adventures like if you're
gonna do this do it yeah don't don't
based on experience don't do it
based on experience
don't go full alcoholic doc brown on the
situation just kind of write it out
i can see it now tony's like hey we
should build a we should build this
metal thing around just shoot some right
there
it's
[Laughter]
yeah but i do think that we are gonna
you know kind of see the consequences of
that in that she's in this you know
new version of reality where she's
suddenly come back we see her
get loki gut with the with the scepter
and everything and i think that loki is
going to want revenge on both
black widow for doing that and on uwatu
for causing that scenario to happen
i think that because it's what if we
could see some sort of a thing where
we end up seeing uh
loki
kill
thor at some point and then that might
possibly lead the way
for jane foster thor to pick up the
hammer
and kind of defend that so i know
that that's a lot of a lot of stuff that
i'm imagining and i'm sorry
but i think it could be cool i think
that it could it could i think it was
super cool cool little loki loki story
in there well and i think i think she's
got a really great point there because
of the fact that we got that
introduction of that
universe storyline from the loki series
but we never saw it come to fruition of
anything else because uh tiny loki ended
up getting thrown into the outside of
the of the of the time you know time
stream and so that would be a really
great opportunity to see if the what if
was you know what if he didn't get
picked up by you know
uh the tv yes yeah brainfart um that
would be cool to see you know if the
storyline went where he didn't get
picked up by the tva and he was allowed
to grow up and become almost pretty much
probably the next ruler of asgard and
taking over things um i think that would
be a really great uh thing to see in the
what if series that i i just i wanted to
add on to whitney's part really quick of
how ridiculous it is
that a
a new natasha romanov shows up and
fury's immediately like this is okay
with me you came out of the middle of
nowhere exactly
i was like yeah you've been asked a lot
questions you're not natasha but you'll
do you'll do it
we have literal shape shifting aliens
everywhere and others and bad is his
avengers replacement team
you know what we need
i will take this
you are a curly haired natasha and i'll
deal with it you're a little dirty
whatever
nothing a shower camera yeah nothing a
shower can't fix you're good to go team
up eventually um
i think i thought one part that really
stuck to me this episode which easily
could be not a good theory but this is
rogue theory is the fact of when
it's rogue theory is when we had zombie
wanda notice that ultron was in vision's
body and how she stopped her magic
powers and how zombie wanda doesn't she
was when you saw that episode nothing
stopped her she was a man like she was
like i'm gonna murder anything in my way
i don't give a so i think it's kind of
crazy that he was able to kill her that
quickly with all those other zombies
around so i do think if we did bring
something from the first season into the
second season that would be a fun one to
bring back because it's not that easy to
kill a zombie especially making a wanda
zombie that's so powerful that it can be
indestructible so that is even better
than or if not even better than
ultravision i just think it's more fun
to have like such a reckless
powerful
not living thing because it's a zombie
um but it's and it also like brings note
that we didn't kill her when hulk was
going against her like she stayed alive
and now she's in a different universe so
i don't know what we're gonna have her
do in this now
uh flat like whatever universe is
completely crushed but i think that
would be a fun thing to bring over it's
hard to know what they're gonna bring
from season one because they did say
which i know we're like don't listen to
what they say for the mcu all the time
because we had so many people be like
i'm not in this season and then they
show up but they did say that the second
season is gonna be completely different
and it has different stories
i do think they're gonna maybe pull one
main one but it's like maybe we're gonna
see more and what if that our different
superheroes not these ones that we're
seeing um right now especially now that
like t'challa
r.i.p um they're not gonna be bringing
them into the second season so like how
are we gonna be able to push that
narrative of black panther well not
black panther um
yeah t'challa
um but i think that would be a cool one
to bring on so the second season is
zombie wanda that's
that's what i'm saying if we had to tie
it in well you guys all had amazing
ideas so i'm going to give you all each
five million points each
exactly exactly you have to keep track
of the points points
yes
five minutes
in the next one you're gonna get two
million three hundred twenty-five
thousand and forty-two zach keep
tracking the points
i promise my next theory will not be
good it will not be good i promise
well we do have some more theories about
the universe that killmonger left behind
but first go check out our new venom
inspired shirt available from our merch
partners at epic hero shop and there's a
limited supply so you should grab one
very quickly and speaking of limited
supply they're running out of the recent
shang qi and the what if shirt so if you
haven't gotten one of those yet time is
running out we're stressing you out go
now just stop the video go down then
come back because we miss you find
little shirts as well as all of our
other great merch options all at
newrockstarsmerch.com and hey it's okay
if you lose some sleep staying up late
for a what if episode but you shouldn't
lose any sleep because of a bad mattress
and helix sleep has a quiz that matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you and they
have soft medium and firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot and even a helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers and eric
voss has a helix mattress and he loves
it and the quiz matched him with a
medium firm mattress with lumbar support
that sleeps very cool and the helix
mattress ships right to your door for
free and there's no need to go to a
mattress store so just go to
helixsleep.com
rogue theory take their two-minute sleep
quiz and they'll match you with a
customized mattress that'll give you the
best sleep of your dang life guaranteed
and they have a 10-year warranty and you
get to try it out for a hundred nights
risk-free and they even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will so
you know you won't have to see them ever
again and helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
rogue theory that's helixly.com rogue
theory for up to 200 off and two free
pillows and hey it's the time of year
where we all want to watch scary movies
and there's no better place to do that
than on shutter the netflix of horror
and you can stream great thrillers
horror and suspense for just 5.99 a
month or 56.99 a year and shutter has
the largest fastest growing curated
selection of thrilling and dangerous
entertainment and stream on apple and
android xbox or however you watch
content and it's ad-free and they have
an excellent mix of classics new stuff
and some unexpected surprises all
presented in an uncluttered interface
unlike some other streaming services i
pay for shutter
we pay for each other i'm screaming on
my face yeah jess and the cat paid for
shutter mostly
loves
like a scary movie
and hey around the office we all have
our favorites on the platform including
trying to busan please watch that
amazing movie mandy the whaling and
poltergeist and they also have great
original films in series and producer
zack's favorite is cursed films which is
great for folks interested in horror
movies history so get started streaming
the best horror thriller and
supernatural content and shutter's
expertly curated collection includes
must-see titles like vicious fun the
mortuary collection and pg psycho gorman
plus all the best horror documentaries
and the hit creep show tv series from
executive producer greg nicotero of the
walking dead so to try shutter for free
for 30 days go to shutter.com and use
promo code rogue that is shutter
s-h-u-d-d-e-r-dot-com
and promo code rogue and finally thanks
to expressvpn both for sponsoring this
episode and for helping us watch tons of
more content than we normally would have
access to you can use expressvpn to
unlock movies and shows that are only
available in other countries it's sort
of like a hack it's really cool so
stream star trek discovery on uk netflix
or rick and morty on french netflix and
expressvpn lets you change your online
location so you can control where you
want size to think that you are located
doing the sneaky sneaky on the internet
so open the app select a location tap
one button to connect and refresh the
page to access thousands of new shows
and movies and choose from almost 100
different countries and watch tons of
anime if you like anime like me on
japanese netflix or doctor who if you
like doctor who like me on youtube
i do love both of those things whoever
wrote this copy does me very well and
this works with any streaming service
hulu bbc iplayer youtube they don't know
if you use express bpn an
expressvpn is the best vpn option
because of its speed you can stream in
hd with no buffering or lag and it's
compatible with your devices phones
laptops smart tvs whatever and not only
does it let you change your location but
it also encrypts your data and lets you
surf the web safely and anonymously
because people are nosy and you can be
very private on the internet with
expressvpn so go to expressvpn.com
rogue to get an extra three months of
expressvpn for free that is
expressvpn.com
rogue all right gang you guys ready for
so this episode showed us yet again
killmonger is gonna kill monger like he
didn't seem all that phased when he
teams up with another version of his
cousin he murdered and but in the end he
couldn't resist the power of the stones
but that leads us to our second topic
for today what happens to the universe
killmonger came from like what happened
to that universe because with no
t'challa and no killmonger who will
become the black panther in that
universe now torn apart by war and does
pepper take over everything like do we
have a pepper creative wakanda
absolutely not how dare you even say
that
nothing's wrong with pepper but
no she is not the queen of wakanda
all this all the food just instantly
becomes less seasoned
it's like we're using too much seasoning
she's got her own store
and one or goop in one section of water
she's gonna say pepper pops would just
start goop wacon
it would be our horrible she'd go to
sherry and be like we need to put jade
eggs in our butts
oh my god
i think it's gonna i think it's gonna i
hate that you even mentioned that i
should jump through the screen i'm gonna
stick my cat on your kneecap i think
and what if or if they wanted to go the
route which i don't know because they've
already done work on season two so it's
like it probably is shuri but if they
did want to take it out and do something
else they could just not have a black
panther right now and they're like we
need to find one or they're like maybe
we don't need one right now um we are
black panther so to speak yeah um
wakanda or maybe they they make or maybe
they make like a like an army of black
panthers oh yeah just one singular like
their elite elite you know super seal
team things like that i'm home of the
seattle seahawks where the our logo our
thing is like number 12 because the 12th
person on the field is the fans
so i'm always about it's very corny but
i'm always about like
that you like we're black panther like
no there's not a singular one so i think
it would be that but i think it will be
how like they did um oh my gosh i'm so
sorry i'm spacing on his name in black
panther um who they were going after i
think it would be kind of like how
they're gonna keep looking for
killmonger but killmonger they don't
know that killmonger is not in that
universe and then like why how would
they know so i think they're just gonna
constantly be like we are still looking
for killmonger he's still out there like
what happens when this like they're
going to be focused up more so trying to
find him than actually like
being like he's gone
he's yeah that's a good point because
because it's it's not like they saw him
disappear they didn't and it's not like
he's coming back any time soon so for
them
yeah with killmonger being like
killmonger being so elusive and
everything i'm pretty sure the next part
when they come back to that universe
they're still going to be on that hunt
i i don't know if they're going to ever
con reconsider
filling that space
uh for the role of like black panther i
feel like that's kind of kind of take up
most of the time which i think is going
to give us the opportunity to see pepper
and shuri kind of come together and kind
of bring together their areas of
expertise to bring something to
wakanda that we hadn't seen prior but i
i don't think we're going to see any
replacement right now i think that
marvel's gonna save that for mcu proper
i think cinematically they're gonna
they're gonna create that step in the
films i think in terms of series we're
gonna stay in that gray area of well
killmonger's not here presently but he's
here somewhere we got to look for him
kind of thing
it is also up to like the next black
panther to kind of
give us that evidence not what if um i
think it's
maybe that's like a stretch for me but
it's like i feel like if someone's going
to announce who the new black panther is
going to be it should be the movie not
one yeah right right yeah that
definitely makes more sense give it to
ryan i mean the thing is sure he was
a great candidate to be the next
black panther in my opinion and
i think it would be really cool to see
that character as black panther and kind
of the thing that i was sort of thinking
about because obviously i i already told
you guys my crazy thing with like loki
and then that got me thinking about jane
foster thor and her taking up the hammer
and doing all of that so i was kind of
starting to think about like what pepper
and sherry could
get themselves kind of into and i wonder
if maybe they might form like a sort of
like a force spin-off where
they sort of do like a like a little
girl gang with like jane foster thor and
pepper in the rescue armor and shuri as
black panther
and then you know they get widow in
there
captain marvel maybe she can come too
who's to say
uh i think that that would be kind of a
cool thing to see to kind of see like
the ladies of marvel that'd be sorry oh
my god get it on never anyone says a
force i get excited i'm a big fan of a
force i love a4 so much and i really
hope that what if season two tackles a
force in some time it would be so cool
hopefully
to make them like maybe they'll be the
next iteration of the guardians of the
multiverse who knows
do you think because of the situation
that happened in in wakanda with the
military and everything in that
particular episode do you think we're
gonna see uh general ross try again to
attack wakanda
and uh
yeah thunder he's not gonna he's
constantly gonna just be stupid
oh boom boom you know like no like the
the reveal of wakanda to the world in
that killmonger episode of what if was a
huge deal because you know no one knew
the opulence of wakanda like no one knew
wakanda had it like that so like in the
comics historically everyone goes after
wakanda like nations go after wakanda
because of their vibranium so if
everyone knows that they got it it's not
just the united states that are gonna go
after that it will after wakanda it's
gonna be
everybody like it's gonna be massive war
it's gonna be chaos i think it should be
one of the which i always pronounce
wrong and i'm so sorry
or um yep
uh i think it'd be
what who like okay so in the comics when
um shuri took on the black panther um
she
wasn't actually or at least this is what
i read she wasn't really actually chosen
um especially when she took the
the whatever and went under they were
like you're not really chosen because
you're too head not like this is a
really bad way of me explaining it
you're like headstrong it was more of a
like you're you you're not you're not
thinking clearly you're thinking too
like with your brain i guess but like it
was just like you might bring
destruction with what you're sewing and
she and they were like she was like well
who else is going to be black panther
then like i don't understand but and so
with one of the dora melange if one of
them took it on because it's like their
virtue is always to protect
and they're also already warriors as if
or as in it
that would be a superhero unstoppable
like t'challa was also a warrior and
prepared to fight but they are like
trained from the jump and that's why i'm
like i trust them with my life and they
wouldn't make a mistake
um so i think they would be able to they
are forming that kind of black panther
collective that could be
an easy way to get in on that because
they're already all trained man just
gotta they're ready to go
i think this would be a great
opportunity for us to see in the fullest
of the comic books uh an opportunity
where we get a chance to see the white
wolf you know uh with bucky coming back
you know maybe even with with
the loss of t'challa and him being his
friend and things going on like that or
even in a sense where uh uh bucky is
still found by wakanda is kind of
reconditioned and trained and is given
the mantle in the midst like what if
bucky's actually in wakanda right now
getting reconditioned somehow some way
and we get a chance in the midst of
everything that his father calls up you
know the white wolf to take on the
mantle and he becomes the protector of
wakanda oh
that would be interesting like the
protection get your ass out of here king
it's like we don't have a black panther
we just have a protector yeah you go
through the white wolf interesting yeah
interesting interesting
we got that we got that little drop of
it from the falcon and the winter
soldiers like well technically the white
wolf or whatever and and that little
like easter egg there and everyone was
like oh my god he's the white wolves
you know but that'd be really cool to
see that come to fruition in any case in
any of these episodes coming up where he
puts on like the full
outfit of you know white wolf it's a
little kind of gaudy or whatever with
the shoulders and everything but still
like if there's a some sense of it like
being similar to
t'challa or black panther's you know
vibranium outfit that'd be really cool
to see bucky in that outfit in the in
the what-if series
oh in the what if series i was like in
the mcu he'd have to leave sam's sister
and i never want him to leave sam's
sister i want to see them married sarah
i want to see them they're very lucky i
really do want to see them married
because i really want like them to be
brothers but yeah yes
yes yes
situations
and buddy brothers because then he'd be
uncle buck and then we
this episode has too many revelations
too many too many
yeah too many good things for this
episode well
here's what's gonna happen guys again
since you guys all had amazing theories
three
million points each which means that the
rogue question is gonna be where it all
goes down baby's
it's all tied up and i didn't just do
that because it's easier to count just
kidding
okay sure
now to our rogue question because this
week russia sent some actors into space
for 12 days to make the first feature
film shot entirely in space and since we
know hollywood won't be far behind and
they love a remake pitch me your wildest
idea for a movie reboot that now takes
place in space
oh there's too many
it's too many
too many too many too many every movie
i'd want to be i'd love to see titanic
in space i'd like to see a lot of things
done in space i i think it'd be really
interesting in terms of in space
to see uh because if you're in space
maybe they can do lo different locales
and space things like that i'd be
interested in seeing like a reboot of
the lord of the rings
um oh my god that would be magical it's
an opportunity where you can actually be
like on a planet where there's actually
mordor and everything in there and all
that kind of stuff like you'd have the
hobbits like
slowly hopping through space and things
like that but it'd be interesting to see
how they take that approach um because
to be honest lord of the rings is a
movie you don't need rebooted but then
in that same mindset you don't need it
rebooted on earth
what about what about it basically
reboot it with a purpose yeah robert
wasn't quickly with a lot of money with
a lot of money in space kind of thing
okay i got one i got one i want to see
jurassic park
now
why i want to see jurassic park and
because we think it's jurassic park in
space yeah but think about the actual
plot of the story right a meteor hit
earth blew it up and people are like
they don't exist anymore no they do they
just learn to exist in space so you are
trying to outrun
yeah they've adapted and what is more
scary than a t-rex that was built from
like two dangerous dinosaurs like in
jurassic park than a dinosaur in space
that has adapted to living without
oxygen so it's like
and these people will be like astronauts
but they're going to be facing every
type of t-rex
freaking
the velociraptor flying through space
every sort of like
any dinosaur freaking prehistoric being
is that you've developed some kind of
propulsion system within their body and
they're able to like yeah they're going
through space fast and you're just like
like you're just right and i just
imagine like we're just doing it's like
we're landing on a planet and we're just
like looking around and then a giant
shadow of a t-rex comes behind us and
we're like
good lord trying to jump away the t-rex
is just like
and like comes in and it's just like
it's all thriller
it's ridiculous
and give me dinosaurs in space two
things that every child would love what
i am imagining
for
my
space movie takeover is that we're gonna
do
a mash-up between muppets in space and
fast nine from the past
oh my god double speed
all the characters from fast nine but
now they're muppets so it's just gonna
be ludicrous and a muppet in space
oh my god that's kind of what i want
like i wanted to be shot on location
real muppets the real vin diesel
is the
yeah and i want them to teach us the
value of family but to do it from space
wow
you know
jess is like i'm sending jim henson an
email right now i'm like
it's like a muppets fast any fast movies
so good it would be so funny and then
now imagine them on the moon same deal
but in space perfect no notes literally
oh my gosh so perfect wow you guys
literally all
chose ideas that i would have never even
thought of because like lord of the
rings in space muppets like
fast and space like all that that's
crazy but i think i'm gonna have
to reward the winning points too
jessica's catch
baby
we can buy lamb now
honey wake up
well that is it for this episode of
rogue theory again thank you to our
guests jessica clemons whitney van
laningham and eddie villenueva for
joining me this episode please support
them wherever they are they're all on
twitter support new rockstars and our
channel by checking out all of our merch
including the brand new venom inspired
shirt and all of our great merch they
can all be found at new
rockstarsmerch.com follow me
entertainment if you want to see me
tweet some weird and follow me new
rockstars wherever we are on the
internet youtube twitter we'll see you
guys all next time we love you goodbye
everybody
[Music]
you